welcome back to the next episode in this
beginner c++ series this time we're
going to talk about a little bit of
additional syntax how memory basically
works and how its represented and an
introduction to some basic variables so
first of all let's go ahead and get a
main dot CPP programmed up and that way
we start doing our stuff now it's it's
often a good idea as a new programmer to
get used to making new files and get
used to making mains so that's what
we're gonna do here if you see arc v and
RC Arg C here let's not worry about this
for now but basically you can pass
values and this function will talk about
functions later for now this will be
good enough okay so at the very end of
our program we want to return 0 as we
did before and let's talk a little bit
about comments first of all I cuz I
didn't mention them in the last one in
there rather important comments start
with two slashes they're ignored by the
compiler so only the text files see them
and you can type whatever you want after
two slashes and usually it's about your
program or about the lines of code so at
the top of a file people will often say
something like I don't know their name
or written by or copyright copyright
code Tekken tutorials let's do this
so that's a comment you can also do
block comments with this sort of deal
and then you can just type many lines of
things you can also use those to type in
between your code
this is really awkward I wouldn't
recommend this but you could do
something like that and the compiler
will ignore this little section so there
you start it and they end it so this is
two ways of doing comments and C++ let's
talk a little bit about memory well I'll
just type it out here
the main way memory is going to be
represented as a bit which is just a
single character of a 0 or 1
representing true or false or yes or no
this is the smallest bit that it can be
hence the name bid o 0 or 1 but usually
when it's represented or when people
talk about computer memory they talk
about it in a bite and a byte is 8 of
these so that would be a byte of exactly
0 value now bytes are often broken up
into split sections of 4 so you'll
notice it's 8 and the reason that is is
because they're often represented with
the hexadecimal characters hexadecimal
is base 16 and it goes from 0 to 15 what
we're used to is decimal
and decimal is of course zero to nine or
that's base 10 usually we see it one to
ten but as a programmer you get used to
starting at zero so it'll be actually
zero to nine is our standard decimal
format for every single character it
could be zero to nine but since we can't
write ten alone 10 through 15 a single
character 10 becomes the letter A I mean
type an arrow that would be great and 11
B and so on until you get to 15
represented as F now so and of course
there is binary which is just zero to
one so you'll see those talked about in
computer science and in programming in
general a lot so the point of me telling
you all that is when you see a bit that
is just 1 that's just a binary 0 or 1
this is eight of them so once you get to
a bunch of them and you want to
represent four at a time so that way you
can read them quickly you represent each
four as a hexadecimal character because
you'll notice the maximum number of
different states and section four of
these is 16 hence the hexadecimal so for
example the maximum state of all ones is
represented as an F so this right here
would be represented in hex as
I'll try to say that it's hex you
usually see it as something like a zero
X and then a zero for this first section
and this other one would be an F so this
would be the exact same as that one
there if that doesn't make complete
sense I would recommend doing an
additional bit of research on the
subject it is the very basics of
computer science so you can find all
sorts of charts and documentation about
this bit of stuff but that should be
enough for you to understand the basics
now on to variables variables are what's
going to be sort of the bread and butter
of your program because with them you
can start defying logic and make your
program do different things and modify
variables so let's talk about the
simplest one a character so when you
declare a variable first you you write
it's type and then you give it a name
and the names can include underscores
letters
caps are fine too and numbers but it
can't start with a number it has to
start with a character or an underscore
or an alphabetical character so this is
a valid name there but if I throw a 1 in
here so it's no longer a valid name but
underscores generally you want it to
define something something that kind of
explains what the variables going to
before so we'll just say this is a demo
character in this kind of case style
where you start a lower case on the
first word and go to the upper case on
the next word is called camel case
you'll see that very frequently there
are other formats to camel case seems to
be the most popular like you can also do
it this way usually I go with character
case when in doubt and then you end your
line with a semicolon so now that is
defined a character takes up one bite so
this could be represented by those 8
bits and it's worth noting that it might
not necessarily use all of these but
computer memory wants to be sectioned up
into bytes just because of that easy
transferring to hex and there are some
other reasons too but that's the
simplest way to state it is because you
can you can represent any byte as just
two hex characters and it's pretty
readable once you get used to it
and some other ones let's talk about
some other ones there's an integer which
is just an end and I'll call this demo
end and a an integer is I believe it's
two bytes I hope I'm not eating my words
on that so it's around this size and
actually you we can test so when your
I'll do a few others here and I will
correct my comments or you can leave a
comment below and yell at me it's also
two bytes guess it would be plural and
there's also a double so these are
that's a floating-point number this is a
bigger floating-point number you'll see
when you need more proficient precision
the line these up all nice okay so a
cool thing we can do if you want to see
the size which you can come in handy
sometimes
is you can do a size of operation so
we're gonna change a few of these to get
together do a size of with parentheses
and then in line we're gonna look do
control D and visual studio code copy
your line we're gonna say these
I'm sort of doing this in an inefficient
way I could have just pasted it twice
rather than eight times or you know four
times sold
you probably don't I'm saying and we'll
put a space here so that it's not right
next to it this size of operation will
spit out the size and bytes by default
so if we run this so let's go ahead and
compile this which you plus plus
main.cpp
that one we have an error and I guess I
just didn't save or something so there
was no actual error there and there we
go
and I was wrong about these entirely
these are for this is eight okay so
that's a whole lot more there we go
so the character yes is one the integers
and floats are four there's other types
of integer if you want an integer that
can go even higher you can go do a long
int or a long long int those can also be
represented as an sixteen underscore t
your society control - there
or there's also 32 and even 64 and these
numbers can just go larger but they'll
take up more bytes so for example if I
run this now our demo and oops let me
recompile it our demo ant is now going
to be 8 for the 64-bit space and if we
do a 32 I think that's the default just
a plain int isn't in 32 yep but check
this out if we go to an N 16 which is
half the size so it will only take up 2
bytes pretty cool huh
so that can come in handy you can find
these limits I don't have them pulled up
in front of me right now but basically
they're they don't you can't go quite as
far with them and the smallest one and 8
it's just a single byte and it only goes
to 256 so if you only need small numbers
and you know that you'll never overflow
you could save a little bit of memory
and make your program just a tiny bit
faster by using a smaller variable all
right well now that you know about the
basics of variables and how to see their
sizes you should also know how to set
them as values character you set as a
value with an equals and single quotes
and you can set it to any character on
your keyboard pretty much
and integers of course you can set to
any integer within its limit and you can
find those limits I'm gonna just go just
go right to the best reference site here
this is the site you want to go to if
you have any questions you go here you
can look about everything about C++ and
we're looking at just plain old hints
and type and you'll see lots of
information about it now some of this
might be really confusing looking at
first but as you get more proficient
with C++ will start looking more
familiar but what we're looking for here
is let's see you'll be able to find the
max value somewhere on here there we go
this chart right here shows it integer
32-bit one and signed as the default so
just a plain int is assigned the 32 bit
int but you can do an unsigned int and
as you can see it holds no negative
numbers if it's unsigned holds plus or
minus if it's signed and there's the max
size of that 32 bit int and you can look
at these for whatever type you want so
you can get your ranges make sure you
stay within range
so now I'll show you that site I think
you'll be able to reference anything
else you might be doing in your program
floating-point number of course has a
following something following a decimal
it doesn't have to but also you can just
put a dot F there to note that it's a
float and doubles the same look and as a
float but I can just hold larger values
and there we go
so you don't necessarily have to assign
them when you declare them but it's
usually a good idea usually when people
initially create them they assigned to
them to zero and the reason why is
different compilers will do different
things with them some compilers may
assign them to zero to start other
compilers might just give them a random
value or whatever happens to be in that
memory location at the time so you can
get some varying results if you don't
initialize them now once they are
assigned you can always reassign in by
referencing them again by just type in
the name and giving it a new value and
you can do that likewise with all the
other types all right I think that
pretty well covers variables and the
basics of variables if you have any
questions leave them below please leave
a like if you want to help this channel
and help my videos it helps recommend it
helps tell YouTube's algorithm that my
videos are you know launched a podcast
so appreciate that and I'll see you in
the next video
you
[Music]